schön dass sie dabei sind herzlich
willkommen bei hallo deutschland und zu
einer neuen ausgabe von corona kompakt
dafür haben wir die polizei über ostern
bei ihren kontakt kontrollen begleitet
und wir zeigen ihnen eine kita die auf
video konferenz setzt außerdem
beantwortet die juristin und
rechtsexperten sarah tacke hier im
studio ihre fragen zunächst aber die
aktuellsten entwicklungen und ein blick
auf die eiersuche mit abstand wohl noch
nie wurde ein osterfest mit so viel
abstand gefeiert und das nicht nur hier
in berlin
die korona regel nehmen eben keine
rücksicht auf feiertage
mindestens anderthalb meter distanz
halten und keine gruppen bilden auch
wenn es schwer fällt man fügt sich dem
ausnahmezustand
wer ist uns aussuchen können wir
bestimmt lieber für den großeltern und
freunden gefeiert
aber ich finde das war okay auch am
isarufer in münchen hält man abstand
auch wenn es bei sonnenschein nicht
gerade leicht es sich an die regeln zu
halten die polizei überwacht die lage
und stellt kaum verstöße fest es waren
zwar viele leute unterwegs aber die
meisten haben sich auch dabei an die
ausgangs beschränkungen gehalten das
heißt spaziergängen
man hat das schöne wetter genossen war
vielleicht auch mal kurz in der sonne
gelegen aber hat auf dem abstand
geschaut und diese disziplin der meisten
deutschen scheint erste erfolge zu
zeigen so gibt sich das
robert-koch-institut verhalten
optimistisch schön ist dass unsere
anstrengungen erfolge zeigen also lassen
wir uns auch bitte dafür belohnen lassen
sie uns nicht nachlassen beim einhalten
der regeln nach wie vor wer kann der
möge zu hause bleiben und wer sein
zuhause verlässt der möge abstand halten
nach erhebungen der johns hopkins
universität sind in deutschland stammt
heute 16.30 130 1383 infektionen durch
tests bestätigt 68 1200 menschen gelten
als genießen
auch in österreich will man langsam
zurück zur normalität
und so dürfen baumärkte gartencenter und
kleine geschäfte wieder ihre türen
das freut die kunden die nun endlich
ihre handwerker träume verwirklichen
können
allerdings müssen sie geduld mitbringen
der ansturm in den geschäften ist teils
in abstand halten ist also nicht immer
einfach und ein mundschutz ist
vielleicht auch für das personal von
österreich sind es nur 30 kilometer nach
bad tölz wo wieder die strengen
deutschen regeln gelten für die 130
bewohner dieses seniorenheims gibt es
aber immerhin ein musikalisches
trostpflaster herrschaften sind halt
relativ ich sag's mal isoliert und wir
haben organisiert dass wir ein mutmach
konzert für unsere eltern dann haben um
einfach ja das leben ein bisschen nach
vorn zu bringen ob ostern wirklich an
wendepunkt in der korona krise war wie
von vielen erhofft kann noch nicht
gesagt werden
die rückkehr zum normalen leben wird
aber so oder so nur in kleinen schritten
erfolgen und auf die gucken wir heute
auch gemeinsam mit dr sach attacke sie
ist die leiterin der abteilung recht und
justiz hier im zdf herzlich willkommen
ja diese massive einschränkung des
alltags wie sieht das juristisch aus vor
dem hintergrund der grundrechte weil die
ja auch wenn ihr's lockerungen cam
unterschiedlich ausgelegt werden
stichwort schulen zum beispiel
es sind wir sind alle eingeschränkt in
unseren freiheits und grundrechten wie
in der bundesrepublik niemals zuvor und
klar ist auch nicht alle einschränkungen
nicht bei jedem sind sie auch zulässig
und das ist immer eine einzelfallprüfung
klar ist aber schon die ersten
unternehmer haben schon vor gerichten
gewonnen beispielsweise der besitzer
oder der eigentümer eines hundesalons
ist dagegen vorgegangen das ja schließen
musste weil er gesagt hat bei mir kann
man doch den hund abgeben ich friere ich
gebe ihnen wieder raus wo kann wo soll
dann entdeckt sein und dann dritter
gesagt sie haben recht das ist eine
unzulässige grund rechtswidriger
eingriff oder anderer unternehmen hat
gesagt ich verkaufen und schokolade
mir wurde gesagt ich dachte nicht mehr
verkaufen weil das nicht lebensnotwendig
ist wer stellt das fest und hatten durch
gesagt sie haben recht sie dürfen
weiterhin öffnen wichtig
eine schüssel habe und wichtig ist aber
für alle unternehmer die den eindruck
haben dass sie in unzulässiger weise in
ihren grundrechten beeinträchtigt sind
da direkt gegen vorzugehen weil man in
einem zweiten schritt auch
möglicherweise schadensersatzforderungen
gegen die kommune gegen die behörde
gegen denjenigen der diese schließung
angeordnet hat erheben kann aber eben
nur wenn man rechtzeitig auch gegen
diese verordnung vorgegangen ist das
heißt klar ist wir haben massive
grundrechtseingriffe die allermeisten
sind zulässig aber eben nicht alle und
das muss man im einzelfall überprüfen
lassen wenn man den eindruck hat man ist
in unzulässiger weise in seinen
grundrechten beeinträchtigt
das wird spannend auch die nächsten tage
nachdem wenn etwas gelockert werde doch
nicht vielen dank erstmal saar attacke
für die einstiegsfrage später sehen wir
uns immer wieder dann die fragen der
zuschauer auch mit juristischen und
rechtlichen hintergrund was sie von
ihnen als experten wissen wollen ja das
ist sozusagen die erste kroner kompakt
runde nach den feiertagen und auf genau
die also auf die feiertage schauen wir
jetzt auch noch einmal zurück und zwar
in zwei ganz unterschiedlichen regionen
deutschlands
einmal geht's nach südwesten an den
rhein in mainz und im nordosten da geht
es nach mecklenburg vorpommern an die
küste gemeinsam mit der polizei um
herauszufinden wie verantwortungsbewusst
die menschen dort die feiertage im
freien verbracht haben
statt touristischen saisonauftakt
riegels mecklenburg vorpommern sich über
ostern ab nur einheimische dürfen
ausflüge im land machen wie zum beispiel
hier nach warnemünde
dieser fahrer mit kennzeichen aus
wilhelmshaven ist aufgefallen
er besuchte einen freund in rostock
beide wollen das wetter genießen an der
ostsee
luft atmen
ja genau vor drei tagen haben wir nicht
rausgegangen deswegen aber für die
beamten ist der fall klar
wir kriegen jetzt ein traktor samt nicht
mehr vorkommen in denen sie ihren freund
abgesetzt haben würde ich ihn empfehlen
über die a 20 das land schnellstmöglich
zu versen und dann in deutschland jetzt
noch vor dem hafen zu fahren also soweit
gestanden der osterausflug nach
mecklenburg vorpommern kann den fahrer
bis zu 2000 euro kosten insgesamt 13.000
mal winken die beamten am
osterwochenende autos raus die meisten
überprüften wohnen im land und sind mit
ihrem dienstwagen unterwegs
für die kontrolle haben sie verständnis
für mich in ordnung es war ja auch ein
sehr freundliches gespräch gerade
deswegen teilweise schon okay so sagen
die anwohner sorgen geschickt bekommen
dass wir gleich durchfahren kann aber so
in der krise sollte man das ruhig
durchführen dieses jahr steht darüber
die zeitung in den ganzen medien und so
weiter wer dann trotzdem fährt wenn ich
das selber schuld knapp 30 feste
polizeikontrollen sind im land
stationiert die beamten schieben
sonderschichten wie hier in wolgast
usedom als dankeschön gibt's von den
anwohnern schokoladige ostergrüße
unsere arbeit wir machen wollen wir uns
auf rügen prüft das ordnungsamt
unwegsame strand oder weiß abschnitte
eigentlich nutzen die beamten die drohne
um abgebrochene küstenbereiche zu
kontrollieren
jetzt wollen sie so auch feststellen ob
ihr größere gruppen gegen die kontakt
beschränkungen verstoßen
eine steilküste ist es sehr gefährlich
also im normalfall wäre hier betrieb
teilweise voll aber nicht an diesem
osterwochenende mecklenburg vorpommerns
strände und küsste verweist die inseln
so menschenleer wie sonst nie in mainz
ist da mehr los seit über vier wochen
kontrollieren janine hörsten und paul
moritz fans die einhaltung der korona
beschränkungen abstand halten nur
zweiergruppen ausgenommen häusliche
gemeinschaften vor einer woche noch war
das schwierig am osterwochenende
beobachten sie fortschritte
allgemein hat man schon das gefühl dass
die bevölkerung erstens das ganze
problem erkennt und dann auch sich an
die vorgaben halten eine fünfergruppe da
könnte ein bußgeld von 200 euro pro
person drohen personalausweis digitale
überprüfung des wohnsitzes schnell
stellt sich heraus das ist ein
familienausflug mit viel verständnis für
die kontrolle habe ich heute ein
spaziergang geholt gut
aufgefallen das ist es blöd aber an sich
finde ich es ok vor dem bahnhof kaum
betrieb weniger züge und verkehr weniger
schwarzfahrer und unfälle
dafür ist der stadt nahe wald ein neuer
hotspot die korona kontrolle hier eine
herausforderung und zwar für alle gewalt
ja sehr weitläufig und wir haben halt
auch in der stadt ganz viel zu tun also
ohne die mithilfe von der bevölkerung
ist es glaube ich gar nicht zu
bewerkstelligen
doch wer hier zum beispiel auf engstem
raum lebt muss ab und zu einfach mal
raus ins freie
neben einfamilienhäusern nach hinten
genug platz haben wir können das auch
drei monate aushalten aber er ist das
eine dusche war die leute sind teilweise
fracht quadratmeter mit vier personen
wie soll das gehen
den überblick behalten auch aus der luft
die polizei setzt möglichst viele mittel
ein
im letzten rennen kam es auch zum
einsatz wo größere feier gemeldet wurde
auf dem grillplatz und da war es doch so
dass zum teil leute halt und weggelaufen
sind und da ist halt ideal sondern von
oben sagen kann ok die einen sind jetzt
daher glauben die andern noch da mehr
polizei überall in mainz meist bleibt es
bei belehrungen die einzelnen
polizeidienststellen haben zum teil
verstärkung von der bereitschaftspolizei
bekommen
wir haben natürlich auch momentan den
vorteil dass keine fußball einsätze und
versammlungen stattfinden und können
dadurch natürlich relativ viel kräfte
einsatzkräfte auf die straße bringen
bei diesen straßen ausschank prüft die
korona streife genauer eine
sondergenehmigung braucht ihr nicht aber
der wirt muss dafür sorgen dass seine
kunst vor seinem ausschank sitzen
bleiben sondern weitergehen sonst droht
nach dem corona bußgeldkatalog von
rheinland-pfalz eine strafe bis zu 5000
euro
das wird er gleich auch noch auf dem
ordnungsamt prüft des ordnungsamtes hat
originär zuständig für gerade
gaststättengewerbe
sie werden es gleich auch noch mal
überprüfen die kollegen vom ordnungsamt
sind mit einer zusicherung des wirtes
zufrieden womit auch dieser fall geklärt
ist auch da wo viel betrieb war haben
sich die meisten an die regeln gehalten
mehr noch viele zeigten verständnis für
die korona beschränkungen und deren
wirksamkeit hängt ja nicht allein von
kontrollen ab sondern vor allem von der
einsicht der menschen
die polizeieinsätze der letzten wochen
zeigen wirkung da sind sich paul moritz
fans und janina herausgehen sicher sie
sind auf jeden fall froh wenn die
pandemie irgendwann vorbei ist von hat
nicht die angst dass man selbst so
erkrankt aber halt dass man überträger
ist bei den eltern bei den großeltern
und einfach dann wieder den dienst
machen zu können ohne bei jeder person
sagen zu müssen bleiben sie mal bitte
ein bisschen weiter weg und die angst zu
haben dass dieses gegenüber dann
vielleicht doch infiziertes also muss
man ist haben und doch so einige corona
kontrollen liegen bestimmt noch vor
ihnen
ja und home offices in diesem job nummer
so gar nicht möglich
wanders klappt das ja noch so ein paar
wochen training mittlerweile erstaunlich
gut den videokonferenzen sei dank und
auch private das bildtelefon fleißig
genutzt um seinen liebsten trotz distanz
zu nah wie möglich zu sein
warum sollte da auch nicht eine kita
ihren morgenkreis per skype beibehalten
[Musik]
morgenkreis in einer hamburger kita
erzieherin maria und musikpädagogen
ann-kathrin sind da die kinder aber
nicht
wie erdmännchen so heißt die gruppe sind
alle zu hause und doch dabei morgenkreis
per skype konferenz der kindergarten
macht aus der korona note 1 von event
die kinder auf der anderen seite der
konferenzleitung sind mit freude dabei
aber doch weit weg in der direkten
interaktion ist natürlich das gespräch
leicht also wenn ich da guck mal raus
dass frühling ist da dann machen wir
natürlich ist ein ganz anderes gespräch
und jetzt zum beispiel dass es viel
leichter wenn die musik machen also wenn
ich begleitet wird mit der gitarre und
wenn an katrina auch so die ideen
einbringen weil das hört man eben glaube
ich über skype also es kommt einfach
besser rüber wenn man da musik mit rein
bringt jetzt jeden kindergarten morgen
eine halbe stunde live unterhaltung aus
dem gruppenraum die kinder sollen die
beziehung zum kindergarten auch in
diesen zeiten nicht verlieren
[Musik]
normalerweise lebt unsere arbeit davon
dass wir mit den kindern interagieren
und uns unterhalten und man ja auch viel
mehr von den befindlichkeiten der kinder
mitbekommen wie geht es den eigentlich
was interessiert die gerade worüber
sprechen die dass das bleibt natürlich
alles ein bisschen hängen weil bei
dieser skype konversationen um trotzdem
im alltag der kinder präsent zu sein hat
sich der träger noch etwas weiteres
ausgedacht via internet wir bringen die
kita jetzt zu euch in euer wohnzimmer
die wir uns immer wieder sozusagen
warten ob die was macht da passiert was
seht ihr das wie die blasen hoch wandern
bildungsprogramm von den erziehern aus
vielen einrichtungen des trägervereins
sternipark getragen jeden tag wenn
volles programm so bunt wie der normale
alltag in einer kita garniert mit selbst
macht ideen für eltern die eltern sind
eigentlich nicht darauf eingestellt so
viel zeit über einen so langen zeitraum
auch mit ihren kindern zu verbringen sie
geben ja ihre kinder in die kitas weise
arbeiten weil die kinder dort andere
anregungen bekommen und jetzt auf einmal
sind sie die ganze zeit darauf
eingestellt sich neue ideen für ihre
kinder auszudenken da es ist gut dass
sie von der kita andere
eine kita in der zumindest in dieser
einrichtung die erzieherinnen nur noch
elf kinder betreuen
alle anderen sind zu hause und müssen
sich beschäftigen oder beschäftigt
werden
da kann die wohnzimmer täter zumindest
ein paar bastel und mitmacht ideen
liefern noch ein beweis wie wichtig
kindergärten sind
ich glaube schon dass sich das bild der
sozial pädagogischen berufe der
pflegerischen berufe gerade total
verändert weil jetzt einfach glaube ich
vielen menschen bewusst wird und der
gesellschaft bewusst wird dass wir die
basis des gesellschaftlichen lebens in
diesem land will das ohne uns nicht
wirklich was funktionieren würde weil
die leute einfach nicht arbeiten gehen
können
das erfolgsrezepte wohnzimmer täter ist
sicher auch dass die kinder ihre
erzieher wiedersehen
alle machen mit sogar der koch könnt ihr
eigentlich und dann eine schüssel oder
intern hören salat für warme tage
kindergarten programm für alle sagen
anrichten
sehr schöne idee und wer weiß vielleicht
wird er die eine oder andere noch
eingeführt woanders auch je nachdem wann
die kitas wieder öffnen können wir
können hier direkt reden denn unsere
heutige experte in die sitzung ein paar
räume und flure weitergeben zdf das ist
sarah tacke die leiterin der redaktion
recht und justiz hätten zdf wir kommen
zurück sagen ja ne nette begrüßt mich
noch mal und dann die frage von familie
partner wie verhältnis nicht bereits für
geleistete beiträge bei vereinen und
klubs zum beispiel in diesem fall ein
golfclub können wir auf rückerstattung
kaufen
grundsätzlich schon hier geht der
einfache juristische grundsatz wenn
leistung nicht möglich ist wie hier im
golfclub den mann nicht nutzen kann oder
ein fitnessstudio dass man nicht nutzen
kann
dann muss ich dafür auch nichts bezahlen
solange ich diese leistung nicht nutzen
kann
es kann aber sein die bundesregierung
plant ja die sogenannte gutscheinlösung
für kulturveranstaltungen
und da könnte man golfclubs
fitnessstudios also freizeitclubs auch
bei dauer verträgen natürlich mit
darunter zählen kommt drauf an wie das
ganze ausgestaltet ist dann würde man
kein geld zurückbekommt für die zeit
sondern eine gutscheinlösung also dass
man sagt wenn das fitnessstudio oder der
golfclub wenn die mitgliedschaft
irgendwann ausläuft das dann irgendwie
die letzten sechs monate noch kostenlos
sind
muss man sehen was da kommt
grundsätzlich hat man aber in anspruch
geld zurückzubekommen wenn meine
leistung nicht wahrnehmen kann
klaus tschütscher hat eine frage zum
thema patientenverfügung fällt eine
längerfristige beatmung also in diesem
fall im zusammenhang mit einer krone
infektion auch in dem bereich
lebenserhaltende maßnahme ja da muss man
wirklich ganz genau prüfen wie ist meine
patientenverfügung ausgestaltet
grundsätzlich ist es so dass
lebenserhaltende maßnahmen so lange sie
noch zum ziel führen also das leben
erhalten und ein leben danach auch
weiter gibt von patientenverfügungen
nicht ausgeschlossen werden aber es kann
natürlich sein dass in einem einzelfall
beatmung grundsätzlich ausgeschlossen
wurde da sollte man wirklich mit dem
arzt und dem rechtsanwalt schauen was
steht in einer patientenverfügung ist
ein ganz wichtiges thema unbedingt
reinschauen und prüfen die es bei mir
ausgestaltet ein ganz wichtiger hinweis
gerade in diesen tagen familienwagen hat
uns auch geschrieben die hat einen
urlaub gebot auf teneriffa abflug
siebzehnter mai sie gehört zur
risikogruppe wir haben alles selber
gebucht sollen wir den urlaub absagen
oder noch abwarten was können sie raten
man abwarten weil erst wenn man die
leistung auch hier nicht wahrnehmen kann
also erst wenn man das hotel nicht
besuchen kann den der flug nicht geht
dann habe ich in anspruch dass ich das
geld zurückbekomme
wenn ich jetzt im vorhinein schon
kündigen kann es sein dass ich dann ewig
schwierigen rechtsstreit habe das heißt
ich würde in dem fall wirklich abwarten
schauen siebzehnter mai unwahrscheinlich
dass man da fliegen kann ein hotel auf
teneriffa oder sonst nur besuchen kann
und dann hat man anspruch das geld
zurückzubekommen ok jessica burg
stichwort gut schauen sehen wir schon
darüber gesprochen bin ich bald nur noch
einen gutschein bekomme was passiert
dann eigentlich wenn der veranstalter
wegen der kroner krise pleite geht wie
zum beispiel im urlaub falls der
anbieter nicht mehr existiert genau da
kommt es darauf an wie das ausgestaltet
wird also wenn diese gutscheinlösung für
reisen für pauschalreisen für flüge et
cetera kommt dann hat die
bundesregierung vorgesehen dass im fall
einer insolvenz des reiseveranstalters
oder der airline die bundesregierung
also sprich eigentlich die steuerzahler
einspringen also das ganze abgefedert
wird muss man mal schauen wie groß ist
der topf reichte am ende
und eigentlich ist ja diese
gutscheinlösung entwickelt worden damit
es keine insolvenzen gibt grundsätzlich
muss
aber wir sagen wenn ein unternehmen
insolvenz geht ist das mein persönliches
pech als verbraucherin stehe ich da ganz
lange schlange von menschen die ihr geld
zurückhaben wollen und im zweifel
bekomme ich da nichts also muss man echt
schauen wie ist das wie wir das
ausgestaltet wenn die gutscheinlösung
auch für reisen kommt umso wichtiger
dass wir darüber gesprochen haben vielen
dank für ihre antworten und die tipps
saar attacke für uns hierbei kroner
kompakt dass sie liebe zuschauer
übrigens auch immer auf youtube finden
und zwar auf dem kanal von zdf heute
morgen ist dann an dieser stelle
professor betrachter zu gast von der
universitätsmedizin mainz und wenn sie
für seinen bereich als biologe eine
frage haben dann gerne schon mal eine e
mail schicken an kroner kompakte zdf.de
werden einige davon hier im studio
beantwortet